Let's say we have this Matrix.
to decompose this Matrix is to create
three matrices that look like so
what are these matrices?
you
Is an M by m?
Diagonal matrix orthogonal Matrix now I
will need to clarify what orthogonalism
Worth or normal is. This is
a matrix containing is a diagonal matrix.
containing singular values
the singular values of
a
matrix which is not denoted here.
We will see that in a minute. And then the V
Matrix or V transpose is also an orthogonal
Matrix or I should say V here.
V transpose is all orthogonal Matrix and
a itself.
Is an M by a is an M by n Matrix, so
it doesn't have to be square in this example is a square
Matrix, but you can perform SVD on Rick on
any rectangular Matrix.
So I would be the number of rows and would be the number of columns.
We want to see how we can decompose this
now to decompose this if we have a free perform
SVD on this Matrix.
We would get.
u s v
Which will be equal to?
the following
Then we have the Matrix S which will contain
the singular values or eigenvalues?
So this is 10 times.
The square root of 2 what is 10 times square
the square root of 2?
10 times the square root of
2 so that's 2 to the power.
0.5 14
okay, I'm just going to
on the up to the two decimal places
then we have zero and then zero.
And then five times the power square root
of two so five times.
the square root of 2
So 7 7.077 point?
that's the Matrix S. So these are the singular values.
Okay.
Now we'll talk about why this particular Matrix is so
important.
And then we have V transpose, which is
in this case.
One over the square root of 2.
so 1 over
to the power
0.70
for all of that
So let me break down the steps for you.
How we can go from this?
To that. There's quite
a bit of work involved here.
Well, then once we understand the steps, we can
apply these steps to any.
Matrix
and then we could
Do image compression we could extract?
You know, if you remember we talked about PC that
the principal components.
for Dimension and I reduction so
all of the application of SVD would be
available to us